it's decision day in Nigeria from a list
of 30 candidates the choice for seven
and a half million voters is now
narrowed to only two familiar faces of
the country's political landscape
Muhammad bazum a former minister is the
ruling Party candidate
he pulled the most vote in the first
round of presidential election last year
with 39.3 percent of the vote
his opponent mamanusman came a distant
second with less than half the votes of
the front runner
the former prime minister and president
is looking to come back to a job he left
25 years ago
Osman is the only opposition candidate
who's not collaborated with the ruling
pnts the others did several times all
big names in Nigeria politics have at
one time or another gone into some form
of alliance with the ruling party
but whoever wins will need to form a
coalition to govern that looks a lot
easier for the ruling pnds party that
won the most seats in Parliament in
December but sixth short of a working
majority
The Early Air has only seven seats in
the 171 seat Parliament
so ahead of Sunday's vote there have
been negotiations between the two
candidates and smaller parties to form a
coalition
the election commission says it expects
the election to be conducted smoothly
but there are fears of attacks by armed
groups in some areas in December the
country missed the opportunity to
produce a president in the first round
of voting but is still on calls to Mark
a historic Milestone Sunday's vote is
expected to lead to the first peaceful
transition of power from one civilian
government to another in Niger
but whoever wins will face daunting
challenges poverty made worse by
covid-19 is on the rise youth
unemployment is high so also is a level
of illiteracy but more worrying is the
violence on the borders
in the west bokaram has raided many
communities and along the border with
Mali and Burkina Faso groups allied with
isil and Al-Qaeda are attacking civilian
and Military targets Ahmad Idris
al-juzira